el ataque se ha producido esta madrugada
cuando varios misiles han impactado
contra una fábrica de reparación de
aviones no hay ningún herido dice el
gobierno ucraniano porque esa fábrica se
había cerrado con anterioridad está muy
cercana a donde nos encontramos y
también del aeropuerto del ibi que es
uno de los pocos que continúan activos
que no se ha atacado y que sigue
recibiendo suministros que llegan aquí a
este país sea ucrania es un ataque muy
significativo porque se pone un paso más
en esa ofensiva del ejército ruso aquí
en la zona oeste y estamos a la espera
de más informaciones porque el ataque se
ha producido muy cercano a una zona de
viviendas aunque el gobierno ucraniano
señala que no se ha producido de momento
ninguna víctima leópolis era una región
relativamente tranquila pero el número
de ataques se ha ido aumentando en los
últimos días y hasta aquí hay que
recordar llegan cientos y miles de
ciudadanos intentando huir precisamente
de eso de los bombardeos